القمه العربيه في دورتها 33 تتزامن مع عدد
من الاحداث التي تشهدها المنطقه العربيه
منها الاشتباكات في السودان وايضا عوده
سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه بالاضافه الى
الاحداث في غزه وغيرها السفير حسام زكي
مساعد الامين العام للجامعه العربيه قال
ان الملف السوداني سيتصدر ابرز الملفات
المنتظره على طاوله القاده العرب حيث
تتواصل الاجتماعات على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه على هامش القمه بهدف بحثي كيفيه
التحرك قدما لتحقيق وقف مستمر لاطلاق
النار لفتل سفير الى انه بالاضافه للسودان
هناك ملفات سياسيه مهمه وتاتي في مقدمتها
في فلسطين اضافه الى قضيه اعاده اعمار
سوريا وعودتها الى الجامعه العربيه بعد 12
عاما من الغياب من الملفات المهمه ايضا
اشار السفير الى الاتفاق السعوديه
الايراني الذي تنتظر انعكاساته على
الاستقرار في المنطقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات